All right,
so if there's anybody,
is there anybody here who's new?
So everybody knows where to find the
website.
Okay,
well that's good to know.
Someone doesn't.
Who is that saying?
No.
Ah,
there you are.
Just look up my name on Google and
you'll find my website and then you can
find the course.
Okay.
And all the readings and so forth are
there.
Unfortunately some of the links were
outdated and if you tried to get ahold
of a Ta,
you probably got a hold of last year's
tea,
but because I didn't update all the
links blindly,
so anyways,
that's fixed,
I hope.
And with any luck the website is fully
functional.
So.
All right,
so last time I was trying to give you a
brief introduction to,
to a way of looking at symbolic
representations.
And maybe I should tell you a little bit
about symbolic representations.
First.
Um,
it's a bit confusing because Freud was
in some sense the first of the modern
psychologist to talk about symbolism.
And Freud believed that symbols were
often used by the unconscious to
represent things that the conscious mind
did not want to become conscious of.
So in some sense,
Freud believed that the things that you
repressed were things that you knew and
understood but didn't want to attend to
or believe or understand or integrate or
developer or even allowed to exist.
And so the unconscious was reduced to
using subterfuge in some sense to get
its point across.
Now it's a powerful argument.
It's one we're going to return to when
we talk about Freud,
but I don't think it's right.
I think,
I think young's explanation of symbols
is,
is better.
I think it's right.
Although there may be times when Freud's
correct,
but I think that would be a subset of
the times when symbolism is used.
Um,
imagine that there are different forms
of knowledge first.
And it's important to understand.
It's important to recognize that before
you can really think about something
like the use of symbolism,
the unconscious,
the use of symbolism by the unconscious.
I mean,
first of all,
there's the form of knowledge that
everyone knows as knowledge,
which is articulated knowledge,
right?
And so articulated knowledges,
often factual or it can be procedural
because you can tell someone how to do
something but and everyone thinks of and
and then there's knowledge about facts
of various forms which which may or may
not be true,
but that's really irrelevant that and
that's often this sort of knowledge that
you learn in a classroom.
Procedural knowledge is a different
issue because you can learn that by
doing or by imitating and it and even in
science,
which is a,
which is a process and an an a method as
well as a body of knowledge.
Even in science,
a lot of the knowledge isn't explicit
and articulated.
It's actually procedural.
This is something Thomas Kuhn talked
about,
for example,
in his famous book on scientific
revolutions,
which because partly when you're a
graduate student for example,
or to a lesser degree and undergraduate,
it's,
it's more relevant when you actually
start practicing science.
A lot of the knowledge that you bring to
bear on the,
on,
on the subject is actually implicit.
You can't really.
You can't really explain it.
And so some examples of that might be
like learning how to look through a
microscope,
which turns out to be a very difficult
thing.
You have to practice for many hours
before you get good at looking through a
microscope or maybe if you're a
radiologist you have to read x rays or
fm rise of that sort of thing.
You can build up a body of knowledge
that makes you a perceptual expert,
but he can't really get that kind of
knowledge without practice.
You know,
it's sort of like learning how to play
the piano,
say,
or learning how to walk or,
or any complex act of perception or
action is seldom fully articulated.
And so,
so that's another kind of knowledge you
might call that embodied knowledge and
there is a memory for them that goes
along with that,
which is procedural memory,
right?
And a lot of what you know is procedural
memory.
And then
there's another kind of knowledge which
is I suppose,
autobiographical.
And that's often referred to as say
episodic memory and autobiographical
knowledge would be your memory of
yourself as an actor in the world.
You know.
So I suspect for many of you,
well let's find out for how many this is
true.
When you remember an episode in the past
or when your mind is wandering and
episodes of the past come up,
how would you describe the forum in
which they emerge?
Are they like hot for how many people
are they?
Like little movies.
Okay.
Is there anyone for whom that's not
true?
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
so when you think about the past or when
the past comes to mind,
in what form does it come to mind?
Stills.
Okay.
But it's still images.
Is there anybody?
Okay.
Okay,
fine,
fine.
There's also knowledge about the past
that semantic knowledge articulated
knowledge and that would be factual
knowledge about what you did in the
past,
but that seems to be.
That seems to be a more thoroughly
processed form of memory because in some
sense what you've done,
if you're extracting out articulated
knowledge from past experiences is that
you have to,
you have to pull out the gist.
You reduce it,
you know,
it's sort of like imagine that you have
a conversation with someone and last two
hours and someone says,
well,
what did you about?
Why you don't repeat the entire
conversation verbatim,
right?
You do some weird job of compressing the
information into something like a
summary and you do that more or less
automatically,
you know,
it's quite a remarkable process actually
because you get the gist or you get the
point,
whatever the point is,
it's not like it's that easy to extract
from a conversation and that's another
form of knowledge that you can,
that you can formulate.
But then there's sort of borderline
forms of knowledge,
you know,
and those are the ones that seem to be
expressed as far as I can tell in
something that's more like symbolic
representation.
So,
um,
we talked last time a little bit about a
parent say apparent acting the role of a
father.
So the parent is embodying whatever
father means and the child is prepared
for that because children generally have
a father.
And of course children are prepared to
interact with men like they're prepared
to interact with women.
They understand men and they understand
women and a lot of that knowledge comes
like hardwired in,
so the child might be observing the
farther across multiple context,
trying to understand precisely who this
creature is,
but then also learning how to embody
that in so far as she might be learning
how to interact with males or he might
be learning how to imitate a male.
Of course there's some of that that's
going on with both genders and then a
lot of what summarized in the in the
acting out in the pretending also seems
to be like just because when a child
imitates his father and is pretending to
be a father,
for example,
he isn't on just duplicating exactly
what he seen,
what he's doing.
In some sense,
you might think of as extracting out the
commonalities of behavior across
different contexts that the farther
manifests in order to get a handle on
the spirit of the father.
And then it's the spirit of the father
in some sense that the child's trying to
embody.
And that would be whatever makes a
father different from a man.
And so you know,
you can certainly.
I'm sure you know perfectly well when
you go home to visit your parents or
when you interact with them on a day to
day basis when your father is being a
father and when he's just being a man,
there'd be voice tone and,
and,
and stance and gays and,
and all sorts of like articulated
phrases that you're familiar with that
are part of the role of father and you
could see other people's fathers acting
like fathers to now it seems to be that
a lot of symbolic representation has to
do with the extraction of the just.
It's like exactly what is,
it's a categorization process is exactly
what it is that these various behaviors
have in common and what they have,
if they're embodied behaviors.
What they have in common is something
like a spirit.
So I think it was hegel who talked about
the spirit of the times and you knew
how,
uh,
if you look at photographs that are like
20 years old,
all of a sudden they're dated,
you know,
for awhile,
photographs look like they're current.
Then all of a sudden,
poof,
they're dated.
And you think,
how in the world did people think they
were normal when they were dressed like
that?
You know,
and there there are are frequently
occurrences in culture where there's an
emergence of a style that seems
consistent across the entire culture.
Like the art deco movement was like
that.
And what seems to be the case in those
situations is that there are novel ideas
being generated,
but everyone is imitating everyone else
as rapidly as they possibly can because
they're communicating in an articulated
way in.
They're copying each other and out of
that you get something like a spirit or
ethos of the time.
And so a lot of what symbolism is trying
to do is to extract out commonalities
across context and often commonalities
that you really don't understand,
like their categories.
They're,
they're almost like pre categories or
their levels of representation that are
trying to represent something that's
actually too complex for you to
articulate.
So for example,
many of you will act out being a mother,
being a father when you have children,
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
you could fully articulate the knowledge
that you have about what it is to be a
mother or father,
and so you have the knowledge because
you can act it out and it's somewhat it
you,
you actually,
you have some form of representation of
the knowledge too because you can
understand that when it happens,
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
you can fully articulate it.
So you could say for example,
that you have an image of what a mother
is and the image wouldn't be just a
still,
it would be maybe a sequence of stills
or something like that,
but it's more like a pattern of
behavior,
your image of the pattern of behavior
that characterizes a given role.
And so.
So that's a good way to think about
symbols,
I think.
And that was sort of the union way of
thinking about them.
You unbelief that assemble was nature's
attempt nature within,
you say nature's attempt to express a
relatively unknown idea in the clearest
possible manner.
Even though that wasn't necessarily
clear and well,
we use symbols all the time for that
sort of purpose.
You see them all the time when you go to
movies,
for example,
movies are full of symbolism.
I was just interpreting the dream of one
of my clients the other day and he
dreamt that he was following a spirit
around in the basement of a house that
was like a maze and the spirit kept
disappearing and reappearing and he
gathered some people around him that was
sort of like a,
I would say,
a social network because he's been
working on developing a social network
and as that social network are
developed,
he felt more and more confident to
search out this spirit and to chase it
around the basement.
Finally,
the spirit manifested itself a ghost.
It was a blue ghost,
ghostly thing.
It came out of a box that was in one of
the basement rooms that had a toilet
seat on it,
so it was like a toilet that was on a.
It was like a toilet that was on a box,
which is just what I said,
and then the,
the,
the spirit disappeared down into the
toilet and he looked in there along with
some other people and there was a huge,
massive maze like structure of many,
many rooms underneath and I thought,
well that's actually quite a common
representation and dreams,
but does that remind anyone of anything?
Anything that's not unbelievably
pathological.
It's like this.
It's like the story in the second part
of Harry Potter,
right?
Do you remember that?
So you have morning myrtle.
She inhabits the bathroom.
She's always diving into toilets and
don't they find the,
the understructure of hogwarts by going
through that bathroom in,
into the,
into the subterranean elements.
Yeah.
So,
so that's a good that,
that realm of symbolism is something
like underneath this is exactly what the
case is with the second Harry Potter
stories that underneath the edifice of
culture,
and that would be hard word sit.
In that particular story,
there is a subterranean realm,
and in that subterranean realm learn
things that can paralyze you.
If you look at them.
That's the [inaudible].
Now,
what do you think happens if a rabbit
sees a Fox,
what does it do?
It phrases.
Why
are absolutely right?
They had rabbit assumes that it's
camouflaged and so as long as it doesn't
move,
then maybe there's some chance that the
Predator won't see it,
and so the idea that you turned to
stone,
when you look at something that's
predatory and Reptilian,
I've been.
That's an old idea.
You know,
God only knows how old that is.
It's probably about as old as mammals.
I suspect it's something in the
neighborhood of 60 million years old,
maybe even older than that because it
was at that point that our primitive
ancestors were living in trees and being
preyed upon by by snakes.
Mostly because our ancestors back six,
2 billion years ago,
got eaten by snakes quite a lot.
They seem to have coevolved with us.
In fact,
there's some evidence from a woman named
Lynn Isabelle,
who's quite an interesting scholar that
the reason that we can see so well is
actually because we learned,
we developed our vision to detect
predatory reptiles,
most particularly snakes,
and the way she found that out.
It was by because human beings have
amazing eyes.
Hey,
we can see like no other animal except
for raptors,
except for birds of prey.
They can see better than us,
but as far as primates go,
man,
we knock it out of the park.
And mammals too.
We've got amazing vision and what
Isabelle did was look around the world
to see,
um,
what predicted,
how accurate the eyesight of primates.
We're in different locales.
And what she found was there's a
powerful relationship with the presence
of predatory snakes.
That's an extraordinarily cool thing.
And you know,
it gives you some,
it gives you some insight into the level
of depth that might be involved in the
analysis of the symbolic realm,
you know,
in the,
in the Harry Potter,
the Harry Potter story.
The second,
the second story is almost a precise
duplicate of the story of St George.
And if you look up St George on the net,
if you Google St George,
you'll see that St George is usually on
a horse.
And what he's doing is slaying a dragon.
Usually it's not a very big dragon
usually,
but it's bigger than his horse.
But it's particularly nasty looking and
it comes out of a cave and he frees a
virgin from its grasp.
That's exactly what happens in Harry
Potter,
right?
Because it's jenny that's down there.
And remember Harry gets eaten by the are
bitten by the bass list.
Great.
And it's kind of poisoned,
right?
And so he's going to die.
And then what happens?
Yeah.
Phoenix comes.
And so what's a phoenix?
It's,
yeah,
it's a symbol of death and rebirth.
Exactly,
exactly.
And so what the story that Harry Potter
story says is that if you're fighting a
dragon,
a snake,
something terrible,
something that will paralyze you if you
look at it and you're doing that in
order to redeem something that redeemed
something from that encounter,
because you often learn things when you
do something that you're afraid of.
In fact,
almost all learning occurs in spite of
fear,
right?
Because to,
to learn something,
you have to explore something new and
that's usually something that's
frightening.
And so what that means is that if you're
willing to face something that's
frightening,
you can garner something of value.
Now I'd also meat.
It also may well mean in the context of
that story and you see this in the
romance that underlies the first part of
Harry Potter is that you know,
the man who's capable of standing up to
predatory reptiles is also the one who
is most likely to attract women.
And I think that that's been a truth
since God only knows when to.
We have no idea,
but human beings are definitely hunters,
right?
And men are bigger than women.
And one of the things that that suggest
is that you know,
a lot of the predatory like activities
that are characteristic human beings
were undertaken by males and some
usually males that hunt.
But anyways,
we can.
We can put all that.
We can put all that aside.
Harry gets bitten by this Basler can.
Part of the reason that this story shows
that is because it wants to tell you,
the story wants to tell you,
so to speak,
that the danger that you faced when you
voluntarily confront something you're
afraid of in order to learn is actually
a danger.
It's a real.
You see it in example like that too in
the avengers.
Um,
I don't remember the guy's name.
He's the black guy with the patch over
his eye.
Who is that?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
that,
the representation of the,
of the one eyed hero is also quite
common.
And you see this,
for example,
in ancient Egyptian mythology,
there's a god named horace who all
talked to you about.
In fact,
I'm going to see.
There's a picture of horace,
actually horses.
The God on the left there on the picture
of the left,
he's got a face like a,
uh,
like a falcon.
And that's because Falcons can see.
And the reason the Egyptians turned
horse into a falcon is because horace is
the eye.
You've seen all seen the famous Egyptian
I,
horace can see one of the things he sees
is evil and that actually he has an
encounter with evil.
And as a consequence,
one of his eyes gets torn out.
An idea there is that,
you know,
you have to face evil.
It will just like you have to confront
fear.
It's fear can paralyze you in.
And the things that make you afraid can
kill you and in a confrontation with
evil,
the same thing can happen is that it can
be so overpowering and traumatic that it
damages your consciousness and like
these things are,
these things are real.
They are real.
I mean that,
that happened to a,
what's the general's name?
A Canadian general who was there during
the Rwandan massacre.
He developed post traumatic stress
disorder and he entitled the book he
wrote about the development of his
posttraumatic stress disorder was called
shake hands with the devil.
And that's really what he meant because
he,
he met one of the guys who led the
massacre,
you know,
and anyways,
he never really recovered from that.
He has posttraumatic stress disorder.
And so these things are extraordinary.
Real.
Now,
back to the basilisk.
Well,
if you're going to confront something
that's dangerous enough and informative
enough to like virtually kill you and
you're going to survive,
what does that mean?
It means that your capacity for death
and renewal is what saves you.
And so you know,
giving you think,
you think about this.
Partly what it means is that like
there you are,
but you learn something,
okay,
well,
once you learn something,
you're not the same as you were before
you learned it,
right?
There's a transformation,
so that means you're the same as you are
because you're still there,
but you're also different and then you
might also ask yourself,
well,
what do you give up when you learn
something,
and that's an interesting question
because you very seldom learn something
that's completely without precedent.
Now if you do,
that's really shocking January,
but you generally don't.
What happens is that you already have a
framework of evaluation that you're
using to interpret the world and you
know it's good enough to get you from
place to place,
but it's not 100 percent accurate and
when you encounter something you didn't
expect or something that's frightening
so that you have to transform your
knowledge.
Generally what happens is you have to
lose some of what you already presumed
before you can learn something new.
You know,
it's like a prejudice or an
oversimplification or an element of your
ignorance has to be allowed to die
before you can incorporate the
information and then grow.
And so you might say,
well,
death is the precondition for learning
at least symbolically speaking,
and that's exactly what the Phoenix is
attempting to represent in the Harry
Potter story.
Now,
who owns the Phoenix Dumbledore,
right?
And he's sort of God of hogwarts,
so to speak.
You know,
so.
So the,
the Phoenix stands in the same
relationship to Dumbledore that Christ
stands in relationship to God,
the father in Christianity.
It's exactly the same kind of idea.
While it's not exactly the same
obviously,
but the underlying structure of the idea
is very similar.
And if you remember maybe what happens
to Harry Potter at the very end of the,
of the series,
what,
what process does he have to go through?
He dies,
right?
And then he comes back to life,
And he has to die and come back to life
in order to defeat.
It's pretty funny because you know,
a lot of people especially
fundamentalist in the US where all over
Harry Potter for it's hypothetically
Antichristian oh cultism.
But you know,
the fundamental story,
I wouldn't say it's Christian exactly
because it's actually older than
Christianity itself,
but the main themes in Harry Potter are
like Christian symbolism in the main
themes to a great degree.
You know,
and it's funny because most of the time
when you go see this sort of thing,
how many of you watched all the Harry
Potter movies?
Yeah.
Like what the hell's up with that?
You know,
this woman got people reading 700 page
books and when they were 10 years old,
I,
I suspect a lot of you were those
people,
you know,
so why were you so interested in that
stuff?
God's sake.
It's about a magic orphan.
What's wrong with you people,
you know,
magic orphans,
but for some reason why an orphan,
well superman's an orphan to.
And if you go on Wikipedia,
it's kind of an interesting thing to do.
Look up superhero orphans.
It's like 500 of them,
you know?
And it's,
that's a very comp goes along.
It also goes along with the idea of
having two sets of parents,
which is also characteristic both of
superman and of Harry Potter,
right?
Because Harry has his daily day to day,
you know,
parents that aren't as real parents and
then he has his heavenly parents who are
as magic parents and you know,
this representation here that I've got
up in front of you and I was telling you
a little bit about that in the last
lecture you could say in some sense
those are representations of your magic
parents and so you can think about it
this way.
It's like you have a mother and a father
and those are your local mothers and
fathers and whether or not you get along
with them or whether or not they were
any good for you or whether you
understand them or anything like that in
some sense is irrelevant because they're
not your real parents,
your real parents or something.
More like nature biology,
the unknown.
Something like that.
And culture.
We kind of think of that as nature and
nurture,
you know,
which is also a symbolic idea,
and so one of the things that young
thought Freud thought you couldn't be a
man until your father died suddenly kind
of an interesting idea and young said,
yeah,
but the death could be symbolic,
and partly what he meant by that was
that you know in so far as you're still
the son of your father or the daughter
of your father or the son of your mother
or the daughter of your mother,
you still haven't grown up.
You haven't taken the projections,
and those will be Friday and projections
that make you subordinate to your
parents because you might ask yourself,
why the hell do you care what your
parents think?
You don't care what any random set of
50,
60 year old people think about you.
Why do you care what your parents think?
Well,
the reason for that I would say is
because you're suffering or benefiting
as a consequence of a projection.
You project something onto your parents.
It's like a quasi identity status and
they're the people who know what's going
on and they're,
you know,
they're entitled to evaluate you and
maybe you're working to achieve things
to impress them and make them happy.
It's like,
well,
why them?
Why them?
You don't care what their parents,
friends think.
I don't imagine you probably don't
really care what the parents of your
friends think.
So why do you care what your parents
think?
Well,
understanding that is part of coming to
understand the dynamics.
Freud would say,
of the personal unconscious because your
relationship with your parents as part
of your personal unconscious and young's
idea was,
well,
you have to replace.
It's interesting because Freud thought
that the reason there were patriarchal
religions was because people projected
the figure of their father onto the
cosmos in some sense.
They sort of personified the cosmos.
You know,
it's like God is an old man with a
beard,
which by the way isn't a stupid theory
as it sounds like.
But anyways.
Um,
so you know,
Freud thought that religion sort of
emerged out of the familial dynamic,
but young thought that that wasn't
exactly right because the religious
symbols like say the one on the right
there where you have God,
the father was representing something
like a metta father,
you know the sum total of all fathers,
which would be something like the
Patriarchy and you need a representation
of that because you are a child of
culture and if you're not a child of
culture,
then you're an incomplete being and you
also don't want to confuse your parents
or your father.
Let's say.
I mean there's masculine and feminine
elements in both parents,
but for the sake of simplification,
I'm going to lay it out the way I am
laying.
You know,
you don't want to confuse your father
with culture or history.
It gives the embodiment of both those
things,
but he certainly doesn't embody it in
total and your primary relationship in
some sense,
your personal relationship is to your
father,
but your primary existential
relationship is actually to culture
itself.
Now,
I can give you an example of that to a
quick example.
How many have you Seen Poor Pinocchio?
Yeah,
so anybody not.
Well you,
you should watch it.
It's a great movie.
It's a bit dated and in some of its bit
preachy,
but fundamentally they knocked it out of
the park.
So Pinocchio is this fake thing,
right?
He's like this artificial boys made by
Japan,
who's was a pretty good guy.
What's Pinocchio trying to do?
Right,
right.
Well hopefully that's part of what
you're trying to do and hopefully that's
a process that this class could
conceivably further.
So what is Pinocchio have to do in
relationship to his father in order to
become real?
He rescues him,
right?
What does he do?
He goes down to the bottom of the ocean.
Was He fine?
They're a whale.
Weirdly enough.
And really weirdly enough,
you know,
I don't know what a puppet is doing on
the bottom of the ocean looking for a
whale,
but apparently it swallowed his father,
which also none of that makes any sense
at all.
You realize it makes no sense,
but of course you're in there like
following it and thinking,
yeah,
well I can.
You know I can suspend disbelief.
You know,
it's just a puppet,
wouldn't pop it and it's looking for his
father at bottom of the ocean in a
whale.
Oil makes it doesn't make any sense at
all,
right?
It makes no sense whatsoever,
but it's a mythological motif and part
of that motif.
It's a death and rebirth motif that
going down to the bottom of the ocean
and being devoured by something and then
coming back up,
so that's a death and rebirth Motif,
but even more importantly,
the motif there suggests that you can't
stop being a puppet Marionette,
somebody else's pulling your strings.
Something else is pulling your
strengths.
You're a Marionette till you rescue your
father from the bottom of the ocean,
and what does that mean?
Well,
it means that you're a puppet of forces.
You do not understand probably
prevailing political attitudes or
radiologists or something pathetic like
that until you make the attempt to dive
down into the depths and reclaim your
identity with history as a phenomena.
You know,
because you might say,
well why should you study history?
It's like,
well,
history is you,
you know,
if you're,
if you're not studying history with the
understanding that you're studying
yourself,
then you don't know what the hell you're
doing and you can't be a complete person
because we're culture where cultural
people were cultural creatures.
You can't be a full person until you
catalyze your identity with your culture
and it's,
it's like an existential obligation.
So,
and if you don't do it then you're going
to feel all nihilistic and weak or
you're going to be old totalitarian and
self righteous and oppressive and you
know,
maybe genocidal and deadly.
So it's,
it's not something that you can just
brush off,
you have to do it.
It's part of an initiation motif by the
way,
which we're also going to talk about.
So.
So that's some,
it's hard to talk about symbolism and
you'll notice,
especially in the first part of the
lecture,
is that my lectures are,
well,
I like to think about them as
impressionist.
And there's a reason for this.
Like I started reading young about 30
years ago,
I would say,
and I pretty much read everything he
wrote,
which is an awful lot and it's very
difficult to read you because there's
not precisely a linear narrative,
but the reason for that is that it's
very difficult to construct a linear
narrative about information that's been
primarily transmitted in images and so
in order to to impart the knowledge,
you have to give people like some
pictures of the whole picture.
It's almost like like laying them out in
space in a sense and so that if you get
enough of those little sub pictures,
the whole thing will click into focus
and you'll think,
Aha,
I get that.
But wandering through it in a linear
manner is extraordinarily difficult.
In fact,
I don't think it's possible.
I also think that's why the kind of
information that's embodied in symbols
is generally not transmitted as linear
articulated knowledge.
You can't transmit it that way.
And so it remains in forums like this.
You look at those pictures,
you know,
so think about those pictures for a
minute.
Okay.
Is the picture on the left?
So that's ancient Egypt,
ancient Egypt law lasted for longer than
Western,
said if you don't include Egypt as part
of Western civilization,
it's certainly lasted longer than what
we generally consider Western
civilization.
It lasted for thousands and thousands of
years.
Right?
And those images are representations of
the fundamental assumptions of Egyptian
culture.
And so those images had foundational
power for eons,
for thousands and thousands of years.
You know,
when you can just look at them and
nothing happens to you,
you,
you know,
you look at them like they're
photographs or,
or blow our flat images,
but they had the kind of motive power
that drove an entire culture for
thousands and thousands of years.
You know,
they had more motive power than
communist ideology for example,
which only managed to motivate people
for about 50 years and you know,
but it's certainly possible that they
had more motive power than Christian
ideas which have only been around for
roughly 2000 years.
You know.
So when you're looking at something like
that,
you're looking at something with power
and the idea that you know that that
symbolic representations or religious
represented representations are,
what do you call a unsophisticated
empirical theories,
like that's an idiotic theory,
you know?
No,
I don't think that anybody who's
educated should be,
should be proposing such a thing after
more than 100 years of psychoanalytic
and anthropological investigation.
It's just not a tenable theory anymore.
So.
So what are the other people up to?
Well,
let's look.
Let's look at the left hand side.
I can tell you a little bit about what
the Egyptians were trying to figure out.
So on the right hand side of the
picture,
you have isis,
okay?
And now isis is goddess of the
underworld and she's also a goddess of
chaos.
And so she's the goddess of the place
that you go when things fall apart
around you.
And it's worthwhile thinking of that as
a domain.
And you know what that's like.
So okay,
so a dream falls apart or revision falls
apart,
or you get dumped by someone you love or
you get betrayed or you fail.
Or maybe you just have,
you know,
maybe you have a,
Ah,
maybe you have clinical depression or
you're hyper anxious,
or you know,
you have some negative emotion
pathology.
Well,
that's a state of being right.
You can think about it as a place and
that place is the underworld.
The underworld is where you go when
things fall apart.
And the representation for the Egyptians
of the underworld was primarily isis.
She was the persona find figure that
represented the domain that was
underneath normative knowledge and the
reason she was female.
It's very complicated and I'd really,
like I said last time,
I really don't have time to explain it
in depth unfortunately,
but part of the reason that the
underworld is given feminine qualities.
There's,
there's lots of reasons,
but one of them is,
is that
that kind of the defining feature of the
feminine is that from which new forms
emerge,
that's almost,
that's almost like there's other ways of
defining female,
but that's our feminine.
But that's a pretty good one.
It's pretty universal one.
And the unknown is feminine because the
unknown is the place from which all new
forms emerge.
Right?
So when you interact with the unknown on
a voluntary basis,
which can be symbolized sexually,
which often happened with Freud's
thinking and with his clients,
you bring forth something new and so
it's a terrifying place to descend into.
It can be hellish because hale is
actually like the worst suburb of the
unknown and I'm sure some of you have
been there too,
so,
or maybe you're there now or maybe you
know,
people who were there.
So it's a very,
very rough place to visit,
especially if you do it accidentally,
but you,
if you go there,
especially accidentally,
you might never come out.
But if you do come out,
maybe you've learned something,
maybe you're new in some way.
And that's another reason in some sense
why the feminine is a symbolic
representation of the unknown because
there is a death and rebirth motif
there.
And birth has always associated with the
feminine.
So,
um,
can I remember the word?
No,
I can't.
The Baptismal Fountain Inn in Christian
ceremony.
So baptism ceremonies has a Latin word
that is basically equivalent to uterus.
So you can look that up if you want.
I can't,
unfortunately,
I can't exactly remember the word,
but it's the same idea.
You're being plunged back into
the feminine underpinnings of everything
and then pulled back up and.
Well,
that's what a baptism is supposed to be.
You're supposed to be born into this
spirit instead of into matter.
And that means that you've emerged as a,
as a,
um,
articulated being that isn't merely a
biological product.
It's something like that.
So,
all right,
so that's,
that's isis.
And Isis is the,
the wife of Ho of ocirus or Cyrus who's
in the middle,
standing on a pillar there.
He's the father and he's a pillar
because culture is like the pillars that
hold things up.
And so in the Egyptian story or Cyrus
was an old king and he was kind of
willfully blind.
He didn't really know what was going on
anymore and he didn't pay sufficient
attention.
And he had an evil brother by the way,
whose name was seth and seth average
eventually chops them up,
wants to take over the kingdom and
scattered them all over the kingdom.
He can't kill him because he's a god and
isis comes up from the underworld and
fines.
Those Cyrus's salice and makes herself
pregnant and she gives birth to horace.
Who's the guy on the left and horace is
sort of like King Arthur were any number
of orphans.
He grows up or or like a lion and the
lion king,
Simba.
Simba grows up basically outside of the
damage kingdom,
right?
It's taken over by scar.
It's exactly the same story.
It's a really.
It's exactly the same story and
horace grows up outside the kingdom and
when he grows up,
he can really see horus.
That's why the symbol is the eye.
He goes back and he can see evil.
He's not blind like his father,
which is the difference between you guys
and dead culture,
right?
So your cultural organisms,
but you're not dead.
You can see and you can update yourself.
So you're like the living embodiments of
history and the living embodiments of
history have to know what history is and
incorporated into themselves,
but also be awake enough to alternate
where that alteration is necessary,
especially when they're doing that to
further their knowledge of the unknown
and also to triumph over evil.
So anyways,
horace grows up outside,
but like he can see he's different than,
oh,
Cyrus.
Partly because he's young and he knows
that his uncle is evil and he goes back
and has a terrible fight with them.
And during the fight,
seth,
his uncle terrorists out one of his eyes
because it's no joke to confront evil.
It's no joke.
It can damage your consciousness.
Anyways,
horse wins and he gets his id back and
then he banishes seth to the Nether
regions of the kingdom because he can't
get rid of him either.
You can't kill him.
He's the potential for corruption in an
institution is always there.
So there's no permanently get rid of it.
There's only controlling it from time to
time anyways.
So he gets his id back and then instead
of putting it back in his head and be in
king,
which you'd expect them to do,
he goes back down to the underworld and
he finds his father there because his
father chopped up is also a spirit who
inhabits the underworld and he gives his
father the eye
and then the two of them go back and
rule the kingdom together.
I tell you,
it's one of the world's most brilliant
stories.
It's a staggeringly brilliant story
because it says
the act,
that act of youth should be the guiding
property of the state because the
horace.
So Cyrus combination was actually what
the Pharaoh imitated when he was being a
good feral.
It's dynamic vision.
That should be the guiding principle of
the state,
but it should be allied with tradition.
It's brilliant.
You know,
it's one of the things that the radical
revolutionaries of the 19 sixties never
figured out.
It's like,
well,
don't trust anybody over 30.
Well that's a really stupid idea,
especially since you're going to spend
half two thirds of your life over 30 the
hell good.
Is that.
So the idea is that you're supposed to
embody your tradition,
men be awake at the same time,
and then if you do that,
then you'd be a good ruler of,
you know,
of yourself,
of your little family,
and if you have an opportunity to,
beyond that then of whatever
organizations you have to be happened to
be involved in,
that's exactly what should be happening
to you university.
It's the whole point of going to
university,
you know,
it's not a trade school.
Not,
not that there's anything wrong with
trade schools,
quite the contrary,
but that's not what university is for.
It's to turn you into creatures that
aren't marionettes.
And to do that you have to follow a
mythological path or you can be chaotic
and random.
Those are or sub,
like I said,
subject to so many idiotic totalitarian
ideology.
But you know,
I wouldn't it either of those paths
because they're not going to get you
very far for very long.
So that's the Egyptians.
Brilliant.
And it's not like they understood that
story.
They told it.
That's different.
It's just like,
can you think,
well,
how can you tell something you don't
understand?
It's just like you can watch Harry
Potter and not have a clue what's going
on.
It's exactly the same thing.
And part of it is,
is that there are,
you have levels of understanding that
make you up,
but you don't simultaneously understand.
You can't articulate them.
So you're a multi levered,
multilevel creature and the part of you
that's conscious and articulate is
floating on a massive substructure
that's neither conscious nor articulate,
you know,
that's in some sense striving to become
conscious and articulate,
but that can never be completely either
of those things.
So it's part of the pain of being half
spirit and half matter.
And
so then on the right,
you know,
you have another set of symbols which
are quite similar.
Um,
although,
you know,
they come about the story in a
completely different way.
So I told you a little bit about them
before you have Mary at the top and
she's regardless,
she's,
she's represented here is that which
encloses everything,
right?
And so in that representation,
culture is the child of nature.
That's one way of looking at the
statute.
There are many ways of looking at this
statue.
That's the other thing that's strange
about symbolic representations because
in some sense you can't exhaust them
with words.
There's always something more you can
say about them and that's partly because
they're,
they're associated with everything.
And so if something is associated with
everything,
then you can talk about it forever and
you'll never run out of things to say
there are inexhaustible.
So,
and you have God the father who we
already talked about.
And then if you notice in that image,
I hope you can see that the figure is
open and there's a crowd of people
gathered around,
right?
And they're all looking at the central
symbol,
which is the crucifix.
And you know,
you might be thinking that,
you know,
billions of people over the last 2000
years have spent a substantial amount of
time doing nothing but gazing at the
crucifix.
It's like why,
you know,
in one answer as well,
those people are all superstitious.
They believe in stupid things like,
you know,
death and resurrection and you know the
Virgin birth and all those things that
make no empirical sense.
It's like,
yeah,
well think again.
You know,
it's not a matter of simplistic belief.
It's a matter of belief structures that
are so profound that you can't
articulate them.
You don't know what they mean,
and so to gaze on the figure of the
dying and resurrecting hero is to
understand that a huge part of what
redeems you in life from evil and from
the things that terrify you is your
capacity to let go of things that are
outmoded in dad and to revitalize them
as a consequence of new learning.
And that's the very soul.
It's your very soul.
It's a very.
It's the,
it's the living part of you.
And that's the part.
The thing that's so interesting about
this is according to the wisdom
traditions of mankind,
that's the part of your spirit that
protects you against fear and pain.
Because you might say,
well,
you know,
if you don't want fear,
you don't want pain.
You should build a big wall around
yourself and wrap yourself up in
Styrofoam and sit right in the middle
where nothing bad is ever going to
happen to you,
but you know,
first of all,
that's obviously ridiculous and second
of all,
you die of boredom in no time flat.
If you did that,
you cannot be protected from the things
that frighten you and hurt you.
But if you identify with the part of
your being that has the capacity for
transformation,
then you're always.
You're always.
You're always the equal of what it is
that's opposing you or maybe more than
the equal of it so you can either depend
on the walls that protect you from
things.
And so those could be like actual walls
or cultural walls or totalitarian
beliefs are rigid thought patterns or
anything like that.
Or you can rely instead on the part of
you that's voluntarily able to confront
things that are frightening and painful
and triumph.
And the deepest story of,
of humankind is that that's the part of
us that's the most powerful.
You know,
weak as we are and subject as we are to
all sorts of terrible things.
What do you need for protection?
That's what you need.
You have to be willing to let go and
come back and let go and come back and
then you can stay dynamic through your,
through the ups and downs of your life
and makes you incredibly strong.
And so,
you know,
one of the things that you could think
about in relationship to this,
and we'll talk about this more when we
talk about Carl Rogers.
Rogers talked a lot about the importance
of listening.
You know,
he said most people can't listen because
what they want to do instead is imposed
their viewpoint on the other person.
Because if you listen to people,
they're going to tell you all sorts of
weird nonsense about their own lives and
about what they think.
And you know,
some of it's gonna be.
It'll say it'll set you back.
You don't want to hear that.
People have gone through that until I
actually understand their opinions.
If you can listen to them,
well then you can open up an exchange of
information and that can transform both
of you and Rogers regarded that as an
absolute necessity in the therapeutic
context and even in the context of
profound relationships.
But he said,
you know,
most people won't do that because they
want to cling to what they already have.
And so one of the things you can think
of,
and this is,
this is worth thinking about for five
years here.
Here's something to think about.
What's your friend?
The things you know or the things you
don't know.
First of all,
there's a lot more things you don't
know.
And second the things you don't know are
the bar is the birthplace of all your
new knowledge.
And so if you make the things you don't
know your friend,
instead of the things that you know,
well then you're always on a quest.
In a sense,
you're always looking for new
information on the off chance that
somebody that doesn't agree with you
will tell you something.
You couldn't figure it out on your own.
It's a completely different way of
looking at the world,
so it's the antithesis of opinionated,
so.
Okay,
so
here's some
you can think of these terms.
Let me give you an example.
So I was just reading this research
paper by one of the people in our
department and he was looking at.
He's found out that people are better
than chance at determining sexual
orientation when they look at cropped
faces that are gray scaled with no hair
for 50 to 100 milliseconds.
That's pretty fast a,
it's like you're not thinking about it
at that speed.
It takes you half a second to think
about something maybe a little less,
but 50 milliseconds to 100 milliseconds.
Man,
that's automatic processing.
Okay,
so he found that if you show people
faces,
then they can predict with better than
chance levels of accurately accuracy
what the sexual orientation of the
person next.
Now we don't know exactly how they do
that,
do that,
but the other thing he found is that if
you're exposed to say to a face that you
judge as a homosexual,
let's say,
and then you're given a bunch of
cognitive tasks where if you stare,
if you use the articulated stereotypes
of homosexual people,
you'll perform better that you do
perform better,
so you see a face that you instantly
categorize as homosexual.
Then you're given a cognitive test that
you can do better at.
If you rely on cognitive stereotypes and
you do do better on it.
So what that means is the brief
perceptual exposure activates a whole
complex of associated ideas and it's not
exactly obvious why those things are
associated it.
You might say,
well,
what does it mean to be gay or for that
matter?
What does it mean to be straight?
Well,
it means a whole bunch of things and you
probably couldn't tell me all of the
things that it means in some of the.
Some of them are things that you
perceive rather than fake.
No matter when you're exposed to that
particular image.
That entire complex of associations,
which is like a map,
the mapping of a personality,
right?
Because to be gay is to be a personality
of a certain sort.
It's to embody a certain mode of being
and so you have a picture of that
personality that's partly made out of
all your cognitive assumptions and that
can be activated at 50 milliseconds by
exposure to just a black and white
picture.
Okay,
so that's like a complex.
Just so you know,
you'll hear about the idea of complex
when you read,
when you read you and a complex is a set
of associated ideas that tend to take on
embodied form and you might ask,
well why would ideas tend to take on
embodied form?
And then answer to that is what the hell
is an idea if it doesn't take on
embodied form your embodied.
So to say that it ideas useful and you
make that judgment.
By the way,
when you find an idea interesting
because like why is it interesting?
You don't know.
Which is also something that's really
worth thinking about.
Right?
Because to be interested in something is
to be in the grip of a particular mode
of being and you don't have any
voluntary control over that.
Some things you find interesting and
some things you don't and you know,
you might say,
well I'm going to concentrate on this
boring thing as hard as I can because I
have to master it.
Maybe after passing an exam or
something,
it's like good luck trying to get your
unconscious to cooperate because usually
it won't.
You know,
you'll be thinking about,
oh God only knows what you'll be
thinking about doing the dishes,
vacuuming up under the bed,
like anything not to concentrate on that
particular boring piece of information.
So back to the back to the complex and
the idea that ideas are embodied.
If an idea can't be embodied,
you have to ask yourself if it has any
utility because there's a trillion
facts,
right?
I mean you could go,
right,
you can go on Google and write down
facts until you died and then you still
wouldn't have got anywhere near the
whole number of facts there are.
So then you might ask,
well,
what good are Fox?
If there's an infinite number of them
and the answered that is there actually
not much good at all,
unless you have a purpose for them and
if you have a purpose for them,
then the fact becomes embodied because
you either use it to change your
perception or you use it to guide your
actions and that's when it becomes
meaningful.
And so you might say in part that a
complex is the tendency of a group of
associated ideas to manifest themselves
in something approximating a
personality.
And then that also gives you a real key
to what the psychoanalysts were up to
because as far as they're concerned,
you're just chalked full of complexes.
And you know,
we,
you know,
you think about yourself is one thing
which is foolish because you know,
you're obviously,
you're kind of like a loose collection
of microorganisms,
something like that.
And there's a certain amount of unity
because he moved the same way.
And there's,
you know,
there's continuity of memory,
but the representational space that you
occupy,
you know,
what you can do with your body and what
you can imagine,
what you can think is,
is very,
very large and it's not necessarily
coherent or consistent and it switches
from moment to moment,
you know,
so you'll know that some of you
undoubtedly have already experienced
what it's like to be possessed by a
particularly stupid idea.
You know,
so maybe you've grown out of one or two
of the stupid ideas that possessed you
or maybe you're possessed by an
attraction to someone you can't control
or you can't control your eating
behavior or you,
you know,
you're a pushover when it comes to
interpersonal interactions because
you're too agreeable or you fly off the
handle and fight and you know,
none of this is really under your
control.
And so all of those things that manifest
themselves not only in your behaviors
but in your perceptions,
your perceptions of themselves,
you know,
they tend to take on embodied form and
use you as the vehicle for their
activity.
So you know,
when you're thinking about something
like anger for example,
think about how it works because it's
quite peculiar.
What must someone generally do?
How much someone generally act if you're
going to be angry at them,
they have to be irritating,
right?
You know they have to provoke you in
some way.
Well,
the mere fact that you perceive what
they're doing is irritating or
provoking,
doesn't ensure that anyone else would
have thought about it as irritating,
are provoking or that that's what they
meant or that that's what's happening.
And my point is,
my point is it's very important to think
about these complexes of ideas as
subpersonalities because otherwise you
really don't get what they're like.
If you're angry,
if you have a proclivity towards anger,
especially if it's an unthinking
proclivity.
Anything that someone says might
irritate you and it isn't like they say
something and you think about it and
then you get irritated.
It's like you perceive the person as
irritating.
You know,
maybe it's just the way they hold their
mouth or something,
it,
it.
It can be very,
very subtle.
And you might say,
well,
it's not me.
It's you,
it's not that I'm irritated by you,
it's the you're irritating and that you
know that's a very difficult thing to
settle because the reality is somewhere
between the subjective and the
objective,
right?
A lot of arguments that you'll have with
people throughout your life are about
exactly that.
Am I,
are you irritating or am I over
sensitive?
It's like,
well,
you know what?
We're going to hash that out for a good
long time before we figure it out,
but the point is is that if you're
possessed by an emotional state or a
motivational state or an idea or some
kind of complex,
you'll see the world through its eyes
and then the facts reveal themselves to
you through the lens of that particular
set of ideas.
So it's very frightening idea because
you know,
we like to think of ourselves as masters
of our own house,
which is completely clueless because
it's obvious if you watch yourself for
like a month that you hardly ever do
what you tell yourself to do,
when you're liable to do all sorts of
other things that you don't even want to
do.
You know,
because you say,
well,
I'm going to go to the gym three times a
week and I'm not going to drink,
you know,
and maybe there's this person I'm not
going to associate with and then you
know,
you don't go to the gym and you find
that person and you go out and drink
with them and you think,
what the hell is going on?
You know?
Um,
but it's,
it's,
it's you,
you're not the sort of person that will
do what you say.
And so like,
what sort of person are you?
Well,
that's a psychoanalytic question and
it's a deep one because you're a
peculiar thing and there's parts of you
that are really,
really,
really old and you know,
that sort of naive view,
the naive young you that you think of
yourself as is like a little piece of
flotsam in an ocean of complexity.
And the ocean of complexity is you.
And part of diving down into the depths
is to start to understand what it means
to be human and all right,
whatever that means.
It's the one thing you can say about it
for sure is that it's bloody peculiar.
So here are some associations have ideas
that go along with these symbolic
representations that I was describing.
So the feminine is off the nature,
and here's some associations.
They're not necessary associations.
There are common associations,
so if you see these sorts of things,
they would make a narrative sense.
So for example,
if you see an old and somewhat evil
woman in an animated movie and she lives
in the swamp,
that makes sense.
Now,
why does it make sense?
Well,
I can't explain that at the moment,
but.
Well,
it's partly because of the swamp is
outside of the standard boat borders of
civilization and it's also a place of
death,
decay and rebirth.
So that's part of it.
Anyways.
Some associations nature,
the is the unconscious.
Why is the unconscious nature?
Well,
because you can't control it.
It just manifests itself within you.
That's the Friday and the.
It's like dreams.
They happen.
You don't know what they mean.
They just happen and so that's nature
operating inside of you.
The terrors of the darkness.
Why?
Well,
remember when you were a little kid,
you're three and you're afraid of the
dark because kids at three are afraid of
the dark.
What's in the dark?
What are you looking for in your closet?
Monsters,
right?
Where are the monsters?
Well,
they're not in your closet.
Hopefully so.
But that's not to say that there
couldn't be a monster in your closet and
it's also not to say that when you look
at your closet,
when you're a little kid that you're
looking at your closet,
maybe you're looking at the darkness and
then the question of whether or not
there are monsters in the darkness gets
a lot more complicated.
I had a client once who was agoraphobic
and she didn't like to take elevators,
which is quite a common phenomena for
people who are agoraphobic and so I was
doing standard exposure which is
voluntary exposure to the unknown,
which is a prime curative process in
psychotherapy.
It's like find out what you're afraid
of.
It's interfering with your movement
forward.
Break it into small pieces and expose
yourself to it.
That works.
So we go to the elevator and you know,
I say,
well how close can you get to the
elevator without being nervous?
So she stands like 10 feet away.
I said,
okay,
well stand there until your board and
then go three steps forward so she could
do that and you know,
made her a little nervous.
And then I said,
well,
I'll stand there until your board and
make sure you're looking at the elevator
and not avoiding it and then take
another three steps forward and okay,
we keep doing that until she's like at
the elevator.
So then I say,
well here's the deal,
we're just going to let the elevator
doors open.
You don't have to get on.
We'll let them close and then that's it
for,
for today,
you know.
And I always tell people when I'm doing
that sort of thing that I'm not going to
trick them,
you know,
there's no tricks.
It's like you don't have to do anything
you don't want to do and I'm not going
to play any games on you.
So okay,
so the door's open and she goes,
that's a tube and then it closes.
And you think,
well,
was that an elevator or a tube?
And you might think,
well obviously it's an elevator.
It's like things are not so obvious,
you know,
because there are many ways of
perceiving something and a given entity
can be a member of multiple categories
at the same time and you say,
okay,
well yeah,
the elevator's not a tube,
but it's an enclosed dark place that
contains the unknown and when you see an
elevator you just see like a conveyance
that moves you up and down.
But that isn't what she saw.
And you might say,
well what she saw is wrong.
It's like not exactly,
but it's not functional,
right?
Decide if you want to take an elevator
then perceiving it as your tomb is
probably inappropriate,
but the point is is that it has a lot of
associations like it's.
It's a place of constriction and
privation and isolation and separation.
And so it has elements of their elements
of its being that overlap with other
things that are frightening and so
agoraphobic are often afraid to have.
Being in a subway,
being a crowded in the subway,
it's partly because they can't get out
and make it to the hospital.
So when closed places are crowded,
places are places where they encountered
their mortality because they get afraid
they're going to die and then they can't
get to the hospital.
So you know,
they come into a room like this and sit
in the middle and they,
you,
you think,
Hey,
crowd of students,
they think,
ah,
place of death.
And it's like,
well,
you might say,
well no,
this is a crowd of students.
And I might say,
well,
what are,
how come you're so damn sure.
It's not a place of death.
Like generally it isn't,
but any of you could drop dead of a
heart attack in the next five minutes.
So why aren't you terrified out of your
skulls?
Because of that?
And the answer to that is you don't know
that's the answer because as far as I've
been able to tell,
most of the things agoraphobic or afraid
of like that they might die at any
moment actually happens to be true.
And so the fact that they're afraid of
that,
it's like,
yeah,
no kidding.
You're afraid of that.
How are other people not afraid of it
while that?
That's a good question.
So that's nature.
That's nature.
I can tell you another reason.
I think
why the feminine is nature.
I don't know what you guys think about
this,
but I was pretty happy when I thought
this up and it took me a long time.
So.
So if you think about the world in
Darwinian terms,
right?
It's a struggle for survival and
reproduction,
which are basically the same thing.
Survival is you,
but reproduction is the survival of your
genes.
So it's a,
it's a survival issue over very long
spans of time.
Okay.
What do we call the selection mechanism,
right?
Natural selection,
It's nature.
Who does the selection.
Okay.
So let me tell you something that makes
female humans different than female
chimps.
I mean,
there's lots of things that they do,
but.
So.
But here,
here's an important one.
If you look at which male and a female
in a chimp troop fathers,
most of the offspring,
it's the dominant male.
But the reason for that isn't because
the female chimps sort of flock around
the dominant male.
Now that happens in other species,
but it doesn't happen with chimps.
What happens is the dominant male chases
all the subordinate males away and will
interfere with any sexual behavior they
manifest.
They'll chase them away.
The females though are perfectly happy
to meet with a subordinate male if
they're in heat and they get the
opportunity.
So they go into heat,
which is something that doesn't happen
with female humans.
And they really don't care who they meet
with.
Okay.
Female humans are much different than
that.
They're picky.
So there,
there are really,
they're choosy.
It's a big deal.
It's a big deal that they're choosing.
So there's this famous psychology
experiments you've probably heard about.
These were undergraduate mail goes out
and you know,
asks random women if they'll go home and
sleep with him,
have sex with him,
and you know,
what are they,
what happens?
I mean generally they say get away from
me,
creep or something like that.
Right?
Are they certainly indicate no,
but then they do the reverse experiment
where they have a female undergraduate
goal,
you know,
proposition essentially males and.
Well,
what happens then?
the males say yes much more often than
the females to.
Okay.
I'm sure that doesn't come as a surprise
to any of you and you know,
part of the reason for that,
who knows?
But part of the reason is that sex is
much more dangerous proposition for
women than it is for men because they
have to bear the consequences.
Literally if something,
if the logically appropriate thing
happens,
which is they get pregnant.
So at least in principle,
women recognize that and you know,
they're a bit more cautious,
although there's more to it too because
women also seem to evaluate men for
their fitness.
Now.
So lots of men have no sexual partners
and they have no children.
That's not the case with women.
Almost all women have one child or more
and it's a rare woman indeed who cannot
find a sexual partner.
Now,
Roy balmeister indicated,
and you're going to have to think this
through because it doesn't make sense on
first encounter.
You have twice as many female ancestors
as male ancestors,
so what that essentially means is that
the success rate,
the average success rate for propagation
for the typical woman is very high,
and the average success rate for the
typical man is very low,
but some men are hyper procreative.
Okay?
So men are subject to selection pressure
and many of them fail.
Here's a,
here's an interesting statistic.
I think this came from Dataclysm,
which is a book that was recently
written about one of those online dating
sites.
Um,
the big one,
can't remember its name,
but he was looking at things like how
the typical woman on the dating site
rates the typical man.
It's pretty funny because women are men
actually rate women on a normal
distribution.
So the typical woman's scores at the
50th percentile and half of them are
above average and half of them are
below.
What do you think the equivalent is for
women rating men?
And everyone laughs,
especially the women.
So what do you think it is?
It's 85,
15,
85 percent of men are below average.
Yeah,
it's annoying.
You know,
unless you happen to be one of the 15
percent who isn't,
you know,
and those are the 15 percent of the guys
who are having all these sexual
encounters in a relatively sexually
liberated environment to,
okay,
so why am I telling you all this?
Women select men that makes them nature
because nature is what select.
And so you know,
you can say,
well,
it's only symbolic that women are
nature.
It's like,
no,
it's not just symbolic.
It's not just symbolic.
You know,
when the woman in some senses the
gatekeeper to rep is not in some sense
is the gatekeeper to reproductive
success and you can't get more like
nature than that.
In fact,
it's the very definition of nature.
So as I said,
there are lots of reasons why these
symbolic representations are setup the
way they are.
All right?
So that's the great mother nature,
the Queen,
the Matrix.
The Matrix is something from which all
things form same root word as matter,
mother,
all the same root word,
the matriarch,
the container,
the Cornucopia,
the object to be fertilized,
the source of all things,
the on the pregnant,
there are more parts of the association
network,
the strange,
the emotional,
the foreigner,
the place of returning and rest,
the deep,
the valley,
the Clef,
the cave hell death and the grave,
the moon ruler of the night,
and the mysterious dark and matter in
the earth.
So those aren't necessarily associated
with femininity,
but they're typically associated with
femininity from a symbolic perspective,
you know,
so like generally like a witch and a
movie doesn't come riding out of the
full bright sun at noon.
Right?
That just doesn't happen because it
doesn't make sense.
It's a dark thing.
And so if you saw that occurring in the
light and a movie,
you'd think,
you know,
what the hell is going on here?
That doesn't make sense.
And the reason it doesn't make sense
because it's,
it violates the,
it violates the complex and the symbolic
complex.
So
who is there sort of.
Those are sort of female,
those are female denizens of the
underworld and hell very pleasant
creatures.
It's like Medusa with the head of
snakes,
you know,
and if you might,
if you ask why would a woman have a head
of snakes in reference to a man?
And that's really simple.
I bet there are men here who knew the
answer to that.
Come on Jesus.
Think about it.
What emotion do you feel when you're
going to approach someone you're very
attracted to and there's an extremely
high probability that she's going to
tell you to disappear,
right?
Exactly.
Absolutely.
Because it's a real judgment,
right?
We're going to see a movie called crumb
where you'll see this in great detail,
but it's a real judgment.
It's like the best judgment is,
well,
I don't mind your physical presence,
but your genes should definitely not
survive another generation.
Right?
And that's sort of generally translated
into,
I think we should just be friends,
right?
You know when you can blow that off and
people do and you have to because it's
part of being polite and civilized,
but you know,
let's make no mistake about it.
There is no more fundamental judgment
than that,
so paralysis and there's no shortage of
man.
I mean,
who are absolutely terrified of women.
I've had many of them in my practice.
You know,
I had one guy,
he was so terrified of women.
He couldn't even talk to them on the
phone.
It's more common than you think so,
but it's generally manifested by men who
do,
who no one cares about.
So it's generally irrelevant.
So.
Well,
that's the guts of the case.
It really is the case.
I'm not kidding.
They're low status man.
You know,
there are people that are generally
regarded as losers and there isn't
anybody who really gives a damn about
what happens to them one way or another
and there's a lot more men in that
category.
Then there are women.
Women are in all sorts of,
you know,
social categories that caused the misery
in distress.
But that one seems to be predominantly
male.
One of the things I'm going to do when
we talk about Freud is I'm going to show
you this movie crumb,
which I just told you about and hitch.
It's actually,
it's very rare thing because it shows
you the world from the perspective of
very intelligent mail losers and that's
just not a perspective you ever see
because it's the winners that tell the
stories about their life.
It's like,
who the hell cares about the life of a
loser?
But this movie is about a loser who
became a winner and you know,
almost as an act of revenge.
And it's great.
Great,
great,
great.
Thai examination of the eatable complex.
Remarkable.
So
those are Hindu representations of
Kelly.
I can tell you a little bit about Kelly
here in the middle.
Representational use.
So,
um,
she has eight legs,
spider spiders spin a web.
The web is fate,
the web of fate traps.
The unwary nature does that.
She's in a web of fire.
The,
a little fire arch there,
which is Amanda Carrillo.
You can look that up if you want,
is also made out of skulls.
That's what's on the inside of it.
So it's skulls on fire,
roughly speaking.
Um,
her hair is on fire and she has a
headdress of skulls.
And uh,
this guy she's standing on,
she just gave birth to him,
which is why her belly is hollow and
she's eating his intestines.
So,
you know,
and that's a daddy.
You might think,
well,
why would something like that be a day
it?
And it's something like a wall.
It's the sum total of all fears and you
know,
you might think,
well,
you don't believe in that sort of thing.
It's like,
yeah,
you do,
you just don't know.
You do.
Of course you do.
You can't not believe in it.
You know,
you're the manner in which you allow it
to be represented and what you do with
those representations,
that's a whole different matter.
But you know,
you're not watching vampire movies for
nothing,
right?
You say,
well,
you don't believe in vampires.
It's like,
that's actually not true.
You believe in them enough to go watch
them on movies.
So like w,
w,
where are you going to define belief?
Exactly.
If someone comes up to you and says,
do you believe in vampires?
You know,
you're going to say,
well no.
And then they'll ask you,
well,
would you spend like two hours this
month watching them?
And the answer would be yes.
And so you might think,
well,
which is the better indicator of what
you believe.
Like what do you know about what you're
like,
who cares about your statements about
yourself,
you know,
you think you have privileged access to
what you're like.
You don't.
You've only been around for 18 years.
You know when you inhabit this body
that's been built up over 400 million
years of life,
something like that.
It might be longer than that.
So it is longer.
I mean that's when crustaceans emerged.
Life itself is much older than that.
So you know,
the people who made this representation
of Kelly,
assuming they made it,
which they really didn't cause it
manifested itself in their imagination,
which is a completely different thing.
They're trying to come to terms with
something pretty awful.
Or you might say they're trying to come
to terms with the category of all awful
things.
Or You could even be more sophisticated
than that.
And you could say they're trying to come
to terms with the category of all awful
things that also reveals new life.
That's a terribly paradoxical thing
because Kelly can be transformed into
something positive.
It's like,
you know,
logical people think,
well,
something can either be a,
it can be a and not a at the same time.
Right?
That's a fundamental logical
proposition.
But then,
so let's say you have a boyfriend or a
girlfriend,
you don't,
you can't hate them and love them at the
same time.
I mean half your life or three quarters
of your life will be in that state.
You know,
families.
It's like,
what is it?
Fifty slash 50 love and hate.
What defines a familiar relationship
might be intensity rather than,
you know,
whether it's love or hate,
it's intense.
And so you can certainly have a
completely paradoxical relationship to
yourself or to another person.
And so part of what happens with these
symbolic representations is that there
they're more accurate than mere logic
because life is one of those life is
composed of oppositions in conjunction
and oppositions in conjunction
simultaneously.
So there's very little about it.
It's logical at all,
but that doesn't matter because you
still have to deal with it.
You have to deal with at a very
fundamental level,
so
you could think of that,
that that representation there as
walk through it.
Again,
let's take about things you should be
afraid of.
It's a funny category.
Well,
an animal wouldn't really have a
category of things to be afraid of.
What an animal would have,
his specific things they're afraid of.
Okay,
and so then the animal would have to
learn what do you do in the face of all
those specific things that you're afraid
of?
So you know,
maybe you,
I don't know you,
you climb a tree if it's.
If you're a monkey on it to Jaguar maybe
and you go under the underbrush.
If you're a monkey on it's a predatory
hawk,
something like that.
You've got these individual escape
mechanisms that are tied to the specific
stimulus,
but then there's human beings who are
capable of abstraction and so you might
say,
well,
there's a class of things to be afraid
of.
It's those things that you should be
afraid of.
Those are the things that go bump in the
night,
right?
You're always exposed to them when you
go to horror movies,
especially if they're not the Gore type
of horror movie.
They're always hinting at something
going on outside of your perceptual
sphere and they frighten you because you
don't know what's out there.
And so the Blair witch project was a
really good example of that because
nothing ever happens in that movie,
but it's,
you know,
it's,
it's frightening and not gory.
So it's,
it's kind of an interesting horror
movie.
It plays upon the fact that you do have
a category of those things to which you
should be those things about which you
should be afraid.
So it's a category frightening things
and then and only something capable of
abstraction could come up with the
category of frightening things.
And so Kelly is like an embodied
representation of the category of
frightening things.
And then you might ask yourself,
well,
once you come up with the concept of the
category of frightening things,
maybe you could come up with the concept
of what to do in the face of frightening
things,
which is not the same as what do you do
when you encounter a lion or what do you
do when you encounter someone angry?
It's a medical question,
right?
You could say,
you may encounter a frightening thing.
What's the thing?
What you should do,
what should you do about it?
But then you could say,
at a philosophical level,
you will encounter elements of the
category of all those things that can
frighten and undermine you during your
life.
Is there something that you can do as a
category that would help you deal with
that?
Well,
the answer is yeah,
there there are in fact,
and that's a lot of what religious
stories and symbolic stories are trying
to propose to you is the solution to
that.
One is
approach it voluntarily,
carefully,
but voluntarily don't freeze and runaway
explore.
Instead,
you expose yourself to risk,
but you gain knowledge and you wouldn't
have a cortex that you know is
ridiculously disproportionate.
If as a species we hadn't decided that
exploration,
trump's escape or freezing,
it's like we explore that can make you
the master of the situation so you can
be the master of something like fire
instead of just being terrified about.
So in one of the things that's
absolutely phenomenally fascinating,
I think is that one of the things that
the Hindus do in relationship to Kelly
is offer sacrifices.
Say,
well,
why would you offer sacrifice to what
you're afraid of?
Well,
it's because that is what you do.
That's always what you do is you offer
up sacrifices to the unknown in the hope
that good things will happen to you.
So in a sense,
you know,
you're faced with something terrible.
The uncertain future that faces all of
you write something you're afraid of.
No doubt.
I mean,
how many of you are worried about your
future?
Yeah,
why?
You're all young.
You're smart.
You're relatively good looking.
It's like,
what the hell are you worried for?
What are you worried about?
Yeah,
right in this classroom,
right?
Well maybe you're worried about what
you're going to do or who you're gonna
marry or what your job's going to be,
or you know,
your health or your family or there's a
whole category of things to be worried
about.
So then you think,
well,
you're worried about the future,
so what are you doing in university?
Well,
I would say you're sacrificing your free
time in the present to the cosmos,
so to speak,
in the hope that if you offer up that
sacrifice properly,
the future will smile on you.
And that's another fundamental discovery
of the human race.
It's a big deal.
That discovery.
It's like,
think about it this way,
by changing what you cling to in the
present,
you can alter the future.
Wow.
You know,
I don't know when we discovered that
maybe when we first started to store
food or something like that,
but it's a mind boggling.
It's mind boggling discovery,
you know,
it's,
it's again,
it's one of the prime discoveries of
human beings.
So you represent the thing you're afraid
of,
then you think,
okay,
there's a class of things that I'm
afraid of that are unknown.
What can I do about?
Well that's a really good question.
It's a sophisticated and complicated
question and we do know the answer to
some of it.
It's like approach cautiously,
voluntarily when necessary,
don't run.
Especially if the thing that's in your
way,
if the thing that frightens you is
opposing your movement towards a valued
goal,
do not freeze and runaway because the
thing will grow if you do that and
you'll shrink.
So that's a bad strategy.
So
I'll just give you a bit of a preview
about what I'm going to talk to you
about
the next time we meet.
Oh yes.
I want to talk to you a little bit about
initiation rites and I touched on them
in a little bit today when I was talking
about things like rescuing the father
from the depths.
So,
but Pinocchio does is essentially an
initiation,
right?
And there are elements of that that are
also embedded in the Harry Potter
stories because for example,
his descent into the unknown underneath
the school and his encounter with the
Phoenix are all parts of a very complex
initiation.
Right?
Right.
And he basically,
his adventures set him on a path that
makes him the savior of his kingdom.
That's fundamentally the entire story of
Harry Potter.
There are,
there are ways of catalyzing that
identity and some of them have to do
with the fact that you're a multilevel
creature.
So this is a tough thing to grasp too.
You know,
when you look at someone you think,
well that's what they look like,
but you know,
it's really not the case in,
in very many important ways because they
have molecular and micro sub structures
that you can't see.
You don't see the back of them,
you don't see their family,
you don't see the political systems that
are embedded in and you don't see them
across time.
Right.
So the thing that's there is way more
complicated than the thing you see.
And one of the ways of starting to pull
your pull your conceptions past your
senses is to understand that human being
exists at multiple levels simultaneously
and that part of psychologically
expansion of psychological knowledge is
to become aware of those levels and to
in some sense of move up and down them
so that you become conscious of them.
And I would say in part the initiations
that we're going to talk about
are,
are
embodied dramatizations of the process
and move of moving up and down the
multiple levels of being a human being
exists upon.
And that the psychoanalytic process is a
subset of that process.
So the Freud,
Ian's the unions,
the people who are interested in
symbolism and the unconscious and depth
psychology.
We're interested in expanding your
conception of who you are,
beyond what you can articulate.
And then you have to ask yourself,
well,
do you believe that there's more to you
than what you can articulate?
And if the answer to that is yes,
then you might think,
well,
is that worth exploring?
And that's,
that's really what we're doing for the
next five lectures or so.
So we'll see you next Tuesday.
No Thursday.